hey what's up babies welcome to another
episode of get close i am your co-host
gio and i'm p-a-r-t park
oh you're like your own cheerleader okay
and i have my baby girl here someone
that i absolutely adore and like
instantly connected with
my baby
bonnie the best schroeder damn did i say
that wrong sure
sure
you kind of are but who needs it
and i'm so happy to have you here yeah
i'm absolutely smitten by you oh come on
um i absolutely adore you
um you came into my life
at a point where i was just like
lost so it was really dope to meet you
in that face because you're just such a
dope powerful
babe
um for those of you that are not
familiar with who she is she's a [ __ ]
an awesome outstanding athlete uh she's
a coach uh you i know you hate this word
uh but you are definitely an influencer
and an influencer in the new sense where
you're influencing
people to do very empowering things not
influencing for the sake of like look at
how cool my life is i think she's
actually a outfluencer
oh tell me more about that term so i
think like um
since getting to know you i think it's a
it's hard to get a grasp of you from
your instagram because i think who you
really are
is so much positivity and empathy and um
like just such this warm vibe
that i think instagram has a very like
or just regular social media is a very
controlled and put in a box way of
putting things out there
so
um my friendship with you i feel that
warmth
on the outside of instagram so i call it
outfit yeah maybe it's because i love
that because i know her i'm i'm locking
that away
he's a [ __ ] stud when it comes to
creating
like concepts and ideas and and new
words yeah he's the best because some of
my favorite people they're just like
check out my shoes right and it's like
it's really cool but then when you start
talking to them in the dms or you meet
them in real life you're like whoa
there's so much more right some people
are exactly the same as what they first
right i've never heard him talk about
anyone like that oh my god you're so
right made me cry in the first five
years sorry
i imagine there will be tears at some
point yeah but you can't do it right now
bart i love that though i love love love
that okay one super important thing that
i do want to bring up is that i don't
know if you identify as this or not but
you are definitely a brca1 advocate yes
okay yes branca you can just say bacca
braca yep yep uh hell is that right i
had never heard of it so we can just
start jumping right into it we can talk
about that what's braca let's dive into
the heaviest thing in my life ever right
now right away um
so
this year has been a monumental like
life-changing year for me and it all
goes back to
about seven years ago i think um
yeah i was
yeah maybe 2016. i don't know um both my
parents had cancer at the time my mom
was dealing with breast cancer and my
dad had uh prostate cancer that he had
surgery before at the same time at the
same time and my parents are divorced so
living their separate lives doing their
things you know very happy with their uh
partners
but they were yeah both suffering at the
same time and going through this and
my mom unfortunately has been doing it
dealing with it for 11 years now
but at the time yeah they were both sick
both undergoing some type of treatment
and my sister is actually a geneticist
so she's a doctor and actually deals in
cancer research so she's the older
sister she's very responsible took a
more
classic life path than i did yeah um
great older sister love her to death and
she suggested that we get tested to see
if there were any um genetic issues that
we had because
if you've got two parents yeah yeah the
chances of this are high right
so
i'm however old i don't know 26 27 and
healthy and having a great time and
living my life and doing whatever i
wanted and i'm kind of thinking okay
this is a waste of time like this is a
bit of a waste of time waste energy like
this is not going to be me and so we
went and got our tests and i think they
can do a mouth swab or a blood draw we
did a blood draw
and
my sister was doing this before she had
kids because it was kind of her thing to
do like if i'm positive
i'm not procreating because the chances
of this getting passed down so for her
this was like a thing i need to do
before i decide to become a parent which
is responsible right yes but also if she
marries someone
that's like really different can't that
like you kind of dilute the amount of
sure sure yeah so if um so yeah we went
and got the test she was negative thank
god
because she had wanted kids and i was
positive
so i was positive for the bracha one
gene mutation which basically means that
i have a deletion in my genetic coding
so i'm actually missing something um
that predisposes me to breast and
ovarian cancer
and so it's not a like
you're 100 gonna get this
it's like your chances are pretty
uncomfortably [ __ ] high
can i curse
so
what that meant for me was that uh over
time my risk for breast cancer was going
to be about 85 percent
and ovarian about 50 55. holy [ __ ]
you're not so believing this you're not
escaping it right so what they recommend
for you with this type of diagnosis is
to have your preventative surgeries
before the age of 35 because that's when
your hormones really start shifting
and you see that shift with estrogen and
testosterone and all those things right
so
um breast cancer being a much higher
risk they suggest that you know a
preventative mastectomy is the best way
to go so you're just removing all the
breast tissue that they possibly can all
mammary glands everything
everything so they're just like not
muscle right not the muscle behind no no
no so just these so it's like muscle
breast tissue fat glands all that and
your skin right so it's that in between
breast layer right it's just essentially
fat
um so they recommend doing that before
you're 35 so that's the diagnosis that i
got when i was you know 26 27. how did
that hit you yeah and where what days in
your life are you here
like are you at a point where you're
like where your sister was where it's
like i do know because i do want this
i've never felt that i've never felt
that like maternal
calling so which is very ironic and i'll
tap into that later but because i'm a
very like caring and nurturing person
but not in that way yeah um
so how did it feel i was
i'm just trying to relate because uh as
a dude your balls are kind of your
identity right well and guys can still
have braca mutations
i see yes yes i guess what i'm getting
to is if a doctor told me that he needs
to chop my balls off
i'm like what the [ __ ] so i'm like as a
chick
are these your identity and are you like
oh my god you're gonna cut my titties
off right well i was very fortunate in a
lot of ways one that like i never wanted
kids okay so i never had to think about
like okay i need to
freeze my eggs or you know anything
weird down that route like i never had
to think about passing that gene on
because it was never a thought like i
never i never wanted that um but when i
was first diagnosed i i was pissed i was
mad and like the
anger i think has kind of like a why me
not my older sister
well not even necessarily why not her
but just to a wine me and it's one of
those weird things where like there's no
one to be mad at so there's nowhere to
really put that anger and that
frustration because my parents didn't
know yeah yeah it's not like this is
just this one right this is just like
the
cards i was dealt like this is just what
the universe
gave me to deal with um but yeah when i
was diagnosed i i kind of felt like it
was a bit of a death sentence
um
in that time in my life i was training
people part-time in the gym i was still
working like my nine-to-five corporate
job
and
i think probably a couple months after
getting diagnosed
and really really coming like
face-to-face with my mortality i left
that job mm-hmm because what year is
this that you said 2016. yeah 2016. okay
i think um because you're like well the
clock's ticking i better do this and i
really felt
i really felt that i didn't feel like um
oh my god i'm gonna die soon but i felt
like
just like mortality is real like
this is happening we're all dying and in
that moment it was just made really
really brutally clear to me and i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i doing wasting my time
in this job that i don't really give a
[ __ ] about it's not fulfilling i'm not
passionate about it what am i doing um
yeah we all yeah
literally three people i uh i was
working for um limited brands so they
own retail companies like express
victoria's secret so i was a brand
delivery and operations manager for
victoria's secret what is that so i was
going around from store to store helping
with store visuals basically i would
come in and tell you if things are
done correctly or set up correctly or
different ways to um
have store displays yes yes
yeah it was fun parts of it were fun um
but i struggled with just like feeling
fulfilled like i was making a difference
like i'm like oh i see you
you know you get into that job that's
not something they tell you like in high
school i started working for limited
brands uh part time when i was in
college just like working
maybe 10 15 hours a week in between like
track practices like retail
yeah yeah that's considered like a
corporate job right like how do you yeah
make those choices um good
uh i just kind of worked my way up
in the company yeah and that's where i
ended up you know 26 27 was in this
brand delivery operations position yeah
and just feeling like i wasn't making a
difference i was super passionate about
i was doing i was really leaning in
towards you know training people in the
gym that's what i was doing full time
and at one point i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
working for someone else's goals
[ __ ] coming to this place that i'm
dreading every day like that's not a
life yeah um
and i left that and focused coaching 100
full-time in the gym and building up my
own business that way
but getting that diagnosis was really
the catalyst for leaving and getting the
courage to leave and being like okay
[ __ ] tick-tock like this is not
how i want to spend the rest of my days
yeah i mean a lot of people would have
buckled and they would have gone into
depression into a dark place and now
they don't want to go to work and like i
mean it could have shifted in such a
different route yeah and i never felt
like depressed i never felt that way
about it um i think there was more anger
and more denial as far as stages of
grief or did you get a second opinion uh
were you like uh i don't trust this
[ __ ] i need a second i didn't
know this guy um i was at the university
of iowa cancer like geneticist um
department and they're very very very
good place there yeah my sister would
have wouldn't have let us go anywhere
else like she was on it um so yeah so
then after the diagnosis
you know they tell you eventually best
route is to have these surgeries
a mastectomy and then an oophorectomy
which is your ovaries and tubes taken
out wow you get the oofers too not done
yet okay not done yet so i still have
two more surgeries in my future at least
and if i want to do anything else up
here like get some big cartoon yeah
let's go [ __ ] pamela anderson
so what they uh recommend is like a
treatment protocol
is um
mammograms chest mris
uh and transvaginal ultrasounds every
three to six months so i was doing all
that for six seven years oh
before i decided to have my surgeries so
it's a lot it's getting really
comfortable
you know legs splayed open while there's
multiple doctors taking a look at you
with the camera inside of you checking
out your ovaries it's kind of cool to
see on a screen i guess yeah um and it's
just to keep tabs on where everything's
at yes yeah so just like an ultrasound
that they do on a pregnant belly yeah
but they're doing it on like this
yeah
that goes up inside of you and they move
it to the right they move it to the left
and they check what does it feel good if
you wanted to get into no
never it's cold that's how dudes dudes
are dudes are like oh you wanna you
wanna put us like a rub a thing around
my wee wee go ahead sure [ __ ] they
tell you to cough and they do grab your
balls and [ __ ] that doesn't feel good
because they try not to do it in a
sexual way they try to yeah
it's you know it's in that sterile
doctor setting it's so unsexual and then
they've got this thing pressing in you
and then they'll press right here so
it's just uncomfortable pressure yeah
right um
they put like a warm gel i don't get no
warm jelly
see if i got a warm gel i mean [ __ ]
thank god they do that they're they're
trying right they're trying um but it's
kind of cool to lay back on the screen
like oh there's my ovaries there's my
uterus it's like not that big not as big
as you'd think um you thought you had a
big [ __ ] i mean no no your actual
uterus i know i just wanted to say but
oh well and as someone that's never had
kids it's just a little guy
i just chilled in there hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa i don't have a big [ __ ] all
right well listen those things it's
amazing
um
but yeah so that's the
treatment kind of protocol that i did
for years and years and years what made
you do it for six seven years i just
never felt ready for surgery
part of it part of it yeah part of it
there was a couple
um months there where like i put off
just going because i just didn't want to
deal with it yeah like i would i would
very much just compartmentalize and kind
of just put that down yeah put that to
the side it's an ugly thing i don't want
to look at right now yeah it's too real
it's now it's right there [ __ ] real
and um
but and i just never felt ready for the
surgeries and so what did you think
worst case scenario was
worst case scenario was that i go to one
of these appointments and i already have
cancer oh got it like i i had a biopsy
once um where i had found a little lump
in my right breast like right about here
and i was like okay responsible thing to
do let's go get it checked out so they
did a mammogram they did an ultrasound
like you found it yourself like a little
dog
yeah and not very big it kind of just
felt like a little
like one of these like a little bead oh
wow yeah that's pretty hard and um i
went in and they did all that and
they're like okay like considering your
situation let's do a biopsy and [ __ ]
biopsies what's up with that tell me
it's basically like a staple gun to your
chest because they're taking a a core
sample yeah
and then take something out and it's
like
and like you're awake but you're numb
and like they're kind of like i've got
like white you know sterile paper
everywhere and it's just this breast
exposed and i'm just bleeding everywhere
and it's crazy because you can't feel
anything and you're looking and i'm just
like that's a lot of blood that's
incorrect this should hurt and it does
afterwards um but yeah i had one biopsy
done and then in
2020 i had
found maybe two or three other lumps
and that was 20 20 right so it was hard
to get the doctor it's mid-covid they're
not taking anything that's an emergency
yeah so i had to fight to get in
and what did you do to fight um lie
oh like tell them that things were worse
than they were
yeah it was a pretty cool health care
system we have i know or yeah that was a
lie was that your sister like going like
no be persistent do it was it no that
was me that was me yeah and like i i you
get to that point where you realize that
oh no one really has my back i have to
be my own advocate yeah because right
now they're prioritizing no really yeah
because right now the priority is covid
and if you're not their priority you're
like yeah i got two lumps yeah could
turn into three could turn into four i
might not die off covey but i'm gonna
die of cancer so i need to get my ass
yeah sometimes like i'm taking this [ __ ]
super seriously and i need you too also
like this is my own life and if you
aren't
aggressive about taking care of it
they're not going to be you know this
whole time um
you're an athlete right yes so as an
athlete
knowing that there is like
this did you feel like a hundred percent
healthy like you're you yes or did you
feel like you're compromised as an
athlete did it become a mental crutch i
never felt compromised as an athlete
but i've always felt a weight on me
and maybe not even a weight but like
this dark cloud looming behind me like
right someday
you're gonna have this to deal with for
sure and it's a big heavy scary thing
and it was like just kind of this
just thing that's always there like
always in the back of your mind yeah you
can't ever forget about it yeah um
so but i never felt compromised as an
athlete no i wouldn't i wouldn't say
that
uh but 2020 sucked because
i was i had all these scares
and i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] besides the
three lumps what else that's
huge that's what i meant that's what i
meant like finding them
and then just the what if this is it
like my my aunt so back up a second okay
the um the gene is actually from my
dad's side
of the family which is crazy because my
mom does have breast cancer but
um on my father's side his mom his older
sister him and his younger sister
have all had cancer so it's just
right on down the line
and my youngest aunt
got cancer or got breast cancer when she
was 30.
and so for me 30 was always like that
age where i'm like okay i gotta get my
[ __ ] together gotta get my [ __ ] together
20 20 is your 30.
no i was 32. okay okay so it was like
okay yeah tick tock pitter powder let's
go um but so i had all those scares and
i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] living in fear
and and being so afraid every time i
find something that isn't quite right
and you know everything that i had
checked out was had been okay
thank god um and then i was like okay i
think i'm ready i'm at a good place uh
mentally emotionally financially i'm in
a stable relationship with a loving
partner that has had experiences with
surgeries and can support me she's
talking about that vincent we also have
him he's like check it out please he's
out of you uh
but just felt like i was finally in a
place where i could handle it and a good
place
um and when you know you have a surgery
coming you can buy insurance accordingly
so i bought like better health insurance
uh because i knew i was going to
schedule it for 2021
and so
what is it november in may of this year
i have my surgery i saw you guys two
weeks later yeah with some amazing boobs
so what was that like so the whole
surgery process was
not as bad as i thought it was gonna be
i've never had a major surgery before
and this is like a major one to start
off with uh the first what makes it
major like are you out for like i don't
know five hours or something like two
and a half for three oh [ __ ] but it's
major because she's remembering moving
completely open yeah she's moving
removing body parts yeah i don't know
what the definition of major is i see i
guess i don't know if like chopping off
your leg is major or like that's pretty
major but like let's just say a wisdom
tooth you're out but i wouldn't call
that mate it's not major you know what i
mean yeah yeah so um i was cut open here
underneath and then what they basically
do is
flip oh my god
and take out all the breast tissue that
they possibly can that they can see holy
[ __ ] and i chose to go there's lots of
ways you can do this and we can dive
into that um why did they make us choose
[ __ ] like that
i'm like i don't know you no more you
trying to do i can't believe that took
only two and a half hours there's not a
lot of breast tissue to remove oh i just
feel like i just feel like
i feel like it would just take i don't
know it would take me like at least five
hours so okay can i even build an ikea
desk in two hours hmm that's true that's
a good point mastectomy what
um
but so there's actually two doctors
working on you at the same time so i
went direct to implants so i chose to
have a mastectomy and a reconstruction
and i was a good candidate to go direct
to implant because i was healthy enough
they thought there was enough room there
that they could put a cute little
implant in right
so um the surgeon who performs the
mastectomy is doing that on this side
cleans me out and then he moves to the
other side and my plastic surgery
surgeon comes in to this side how
efficient
pops in the little implant gets it all
adjusted i also have cadaver tissue in
there like tendons and ligaments from a
cadaver why do you have that for to help
hold them in place
as there's none of me in there
to help hold it in place
that i've got cut over parts in there
too like that's crazy crazy it's
absolutely crazy that if you think about
it they're really not yours and then
they're really not yours they're really
not messing up someone else is a little
bit a little bit who knows who that is
yeah
right i could have these like kind of
haunted titties you know dude there's
times where i'm like i don't want to go
second uh storage uh secondhand shopping
just because i'm like i don't know what
spirit's clinging on to this [ __ ]
piece of garment or furniture and you've
got dead person body whatever spirits
are clinging on to their like one seems
to be dope so i think we're all right
all right good but that's how they do it
so it's pretty efficient so it doesn't
take five hours like nike a desk uh
and then they stitch you up and so my my
scars are here and i chose to go over
the muscle i feel like we were just
talking about this yeah the other
morning in the gym um but i started
repping 135 on the larson i'm like what
the [ __ ] did you just have boobs surgery
yeah she was like yeah like six months
ago i'm like that's [ __ ] fast
recovering are you under
um i don't know i think i'm over okay
yeah okay i'm over so over typically the
recovery times a little bit quicker
because they aren't damaging the muscle
yeah so it's muscle implant skin right
um with a just a normal breast
augmentation they kind of create a
pocket for the implant to go into
me all that tissue is removed so like
the whole thing is a it's a pocket so
it's just skin implant um
but yeah that's the procedure and
i think probably the four days after
that were the toughest i felt like i had
like a plate on my back like just a
weight on my back because of the weight
no not even because of size i don't know
if it was just like positioning or what
because you have to sleep on your back
for so
like weeks and weeks um but my back was
just so uncomfortable and that was the
worst part um
but four days were kind of tricky and
then the fifth day i was like draining
stuff out and like yeah yeah so that's
the other thing that they do um they
don't do for breast augmentation yeah i
did have drains so i had little
incisions on my side and i had drains
what's that for
uh to help drain all the fluid that
builds up so i have drains into these
little um little i don't know broncos
little plastic uh things that catch it
yeah and you have to empty them like
twice a day and record how much did you
try smelling you're draining no i didn't
because it doesn't
it doesn't look like something
everything that comes out of me i gotta
at least smell it a little bit just like
to see like what i'm losing he has some
gnarly [ __ ] come out of him man i've
seen some black [ __ ] come out of so he
couldn't hear every okay this is a
tradition and we'll go back sorry but
every time we go to hawaii every [ __ ]
time we go to hawaii all of a sudden he
can't hear out of one ear so this is
tradition i'm snorkeling like five times
the amount anyone else's so then we have
to go to the drugstore get the ear
cleaning spray bottle type thingy then
this black is it like a suction uh it's
like a spray like it just it creates
like a what is that a tornado yeah
whirlpool yeah yeah like a little toy
yeah
yeah so then it pulls out this black
thing and he always wants me to see it
and then he was like he smelled it oh
you don't know is it both ears or is it
always one ear
it's usually one or two
one
are you getting bloody noses too
i oh that's always just constant he had
a bunch of shit's good like when he
popped up out of the lake in utah and
just i'm like what happened to you down
there yeah you meet a sea creature and
then get in a fight what happened
there's been times where i'm snorkeling
and like i'm going really deep and as
i'm holding my breath and there's a lot
of pressure like this okay and i'm
looking around a coral and then i see
like a red cloud come out i'm like son
of a [ __ ] wow so i don't know how to
get out of the water now and it's just
every time and t and tyka gets yeah you
know too so they both walk around with
like tissue when they're not so funny um
so you didn't smell the stuff that's i
didn't smell anything
out of my body um and if you've seen the
pictures they had like these crazy uh
they looked like alien titties on yeah
for a while they were like vacuum sealed
purple wound vacs yeah and like legit
vacuum sealed like those meals that
showed up right like yes
it's on you you can't even pull it off
no so i didn't see them i didn't see my
boobs for the first week
right so on day five i woke up feeling
pretty good took a little walk whatever
day six so wait at this point though are
you already relieved are you just like
uh yes yes like yeah i don't have to
worry about yeah
cool yeah i'm i'm like wow i never have
to have another mammogram again good
um why because they're smashing your
teeth so uncomfortable i feel like no
one tells you how painful they are they
suck yeah i've never heard this is it a
girl doctor or a guy doctor that does it
uh i've only had women
but like it makes you why are they
pressing so hard pancake because they're
making cause they have to yeah yeah
because that's how they have to get the
images i think i'm sure it was a man
that invented the whole right they
didn't understand yeah that's right
always make sure i take tylenol before
going wow
i've never had one
yeah and i don't know how it works with
um implants if they just do ultrasounds
instead but
i don't i know i never have to do them
again which is great but so day five
woke up feeling pretty good took a walk
um so right now the only anxiety is okay
i'm waiting on my pathology report
because they took all this tissue and
they need to test it make sure that's
good um and then the other you know
kind of uh vain anxiety is what am i
gonna look like absolutely what if
they're lopsided because the other thing
is i told the doctors like just make me
as big as you can
without doing the expanders because i
didn't want to [ __ ] with those what's an
example
so expander is basically a balloon that
goes into you and they keep it pumped up
until it's big enough for the size
implant that you want
so you can have those in from anywhere
from like three to six months
and then you have to go back and get
your final implant and then there's a
recovery from that
so your recovery time can be gnarly
right
so um so yeah there's the concern about
the pathology report there's the concern
about how am i gonna look cause i
haven't seen them i don't know what's
going on i'm like they feel bigger i
also know i'm super swollen and all that
it's very honest of you to admit that a
lot of people wouldn't what part uh that
you're like the the vanity part of it oh
but that's such an important part yeah
but no one really would say that yeah
that's tight also if you paid for it you
want something good well and it's you
and that's one of those things like with
breast augmentation like you're picking
your size you're figuring it out with a
doctor but me i'm just like okay we'll
see what i wake up with yeah like you're
fully trusting oh i see that you know
yeah
it's gonna be okay yeah and they're like
just so you know like there is a chance
that we get in there and things don't
look good and we can't give you implants
so that's another thing so you won't
even know until you wake you just don't
know you're kind of at the mercy to the
doctors and whatever they see in there
so day six i get an email and it's like
uh your pathology port is back you can
go read it in your chart whatever go log
in
and so i don't think i i don't think i
told you this
and so i'm i'm scrolling through and
it's like uh pathology came back
negative i'm like
oh
now i can finally let go of that piece
yes i can breathe like
the really hard part is done
and i'm scrolling i'm reading it and
it's medical jargon some kind of
understanding kind of not they said
they'd also call me that day to explain
and i'm going through the um the
specimens right like what they took
and under the specimens it says
right nipple left nipple
i'm like i thought we were doing a
nipple sparing mastectomy because i
don't have cancer so they should be able
to leave those
but i'm gonna make a phone call
right because you can't even check it at
this point i don't because no one has
nipples yeah exactly stuff exactly so
that was a really weird nipple specimen
means they take the whole thing or just
she wasn't sure i wasn't sure at this
point she's not sure she's just
like barbie right so i'm like okay
i need to wrap my brain around that your
nipples before this happened yo my
titties were so good before okay so then
you're really gonna be sad okay i got it
like super cute super symmetrical super
sensitive
killer titties yeah i saw them they were
great great
um so i'm like you know what
okay
if they're gone that's fine and i'm like
already trying to like wrap my brain
around it like come to terms with
being nippleless and just kind of this
barbie look
at that chest and it's tight now you can
walk around shirtless not offending
anybody because there's no heaven for
bed you know
so i'm like okay well since i get my uh
wound vacs my drains out and all that
off tomorrow i'm gonna make a phone call
just so i'm not surprised
and uh i call the doctors and i'm like
i'm reading through my pathology report
and under specimens it says right nipple
left nipple
do i still have nipples
and like get to the point really strange
question i never thought i'd have to ask
right but i'd just like to know before i
get in tomorrow and they take all the
dressings off and they're like oh
everything went according to plan yeah
what does that mean it means i still
have nipples oh okay
still there that's not a yes or no
answer yes i still have nipples so i was
like okay great
another weight off my shoulder like this
is good this is good well is the right
nipple on the right boob well imagine
this guy the doctor got back i don't
know and honestly i probably couldn't
even tell yet right like they're there
that's all that matters yeah thank you
to my favorite best fiends
my source of happiness when i finally
have my me time it is a game
that is just
so dang cute okay so it's a it's a game
that you play on your phone you do not
need internet access you do not you
could be on airplane mode and you're
still gonna be able to play this game um
basic premise here is
you collect bug friends the only way you
can get bug friends or collect these
these these cute little creepy looking
bugs uh is by
advancing to different levels
but the way you advance is you're trying
to protect your garden from these nasty
nasty disgusting
yucky slugs that keep these or at least
trying to destroy this garden aha now
this is where the bugs come in the bugs
have different powers and uh they use
them against these nasty bugs to save
our beautiful garden what i love about
it is not only is it entertaining it's
challenging but the visuals are just so
dang cute you never see the same
landscape more than once there's
different levels some of them are sunny
some of them are snowy some of them are
in the jungles some of them are in the
desert it's just
so vibrant so happy
it it really does keep me in my happy
place
so thank you to best fiends
don't miss out if you want a good old
challenging fun
time and it's really fun for the whole
family taika loves this download best
fiends for free today at the apple app
store or google play that's best fiends
think of it as friends but without the r
best fiends um so went in on day seven
to get my drains out my uh moonbacks off
and like i'm swollen and i feel huge and
i'm like oh my gosh it was overwhelming
who's chat and i think you probably saw
him a couple days later i sent a video
yep and i'm like oh my god dude look at
these titties like what do i do yeah
they were facing different directions
they were like really up here they were
really high they were kind of um just
like lumpy and kind of like misshapen
and they had been vacuum sealed so they
were kind of just like trying to and
it's a breath of fresh air yeah it's new
skin that hasn't been taught a little
bit right i mean that is taut that
hasn't been stretched yes yes incredibly
tight incredibly high all that um which
is what happens when you get breast
augmentation they eventually drop
yes yes that's a normal thing yes and i
feel like they sit much more naturally
now um but on day uh
nine i had a good solid cry because i
just wasn't happy with how they looked
oh no
and matt's like hang on are you still
taking painkillers i was like yeah he's
like we're done with those he's like
back to weed tomorrow what was his
reasoning i was just uh emotional for no
reason really like everything was fine
and um i think he had seen me topless
and he didn't have
oh my god you look great oh reaction he
was like yeah they're fine like
everything's gonna be fine and i'm just
like
you don't love them you know like i
really needed that validation because i
was just in such a sensitive spot he was
probably just running from like a health
point of view yeah
yeah and to be fair they looked really
weird then so like but i was crying he's
just like hang on how long have you been
taking the hydrocodone like nine days
he's like that's good let's get off that
and
me having no experience with pain
killers or pain pills at all like that i
was like okay that's
sure and i then looking back i'm like
man that week i was so hazy and just
foggy and like mental clarity was not
there like you could say something to me
and i'd be looking at you i'd be like
what like i would just wouldn't like uh
digest anything you were saying yeah so
those were not cool to be on for a week
um
yeah i saw and then i saw you guys on
like day 12 day 13 in utah yeah why why
did he say get back on weed
um just to sleep oh yeah okay gotcha
because that was it was just definitely
like an emotional roller coaster and the
mental fogginess was the worst part like
couldn't even really have a conversation
that well um so then got back to to
smoking like nightly which we usually do
to sleep well and then um yeah yeah i
saw you guys a couple couple days later
what a thought i love the fact that you
were like
that's it i'm taking this [ __ ] i'm gonna
own it and i'm just gonna keep [ __ ]
moving forward yeah that's scary man and
and for me like the big thing i
announced you know that i was gonna have
surgery and almost never yes yes online
on my instagram and i had never been
vocal about it before and i think that
was what was also keeping me in denial
was not talking about it yeah it's not
that real and not being open about it
yeah because when you say it when you
speak it out into the universe it's the
truth it's reality yeah this is your
reality
and what made you talk about it when i
decided to have surgery when i actually
had a date but you could have just had
the surgery and still not talk about it
why why sharing that's true i decided i
wanted to be an advocate for yes yeah
yeah i'm like there's a lot of other
women out there that are dealing with
this and men too men can obviously carry
the mutations
um and i'm like man i'm in such a unique
position where i have a platform
i have a voice i have people that listen
and and can care what i say
and i'm also an athlete it's like this
puts me in a unique position to talk
about
lots of different parts of this process
and
you know my feelings throughout it and
you know getting back to lifting and
returning to that identity as an athlete
and i don't look at the bracka piece as
my whole identity but nor do i look at
being an athlete as my whole identity
anymore either you know um so i think
that really being more open and
communicating with others about it has
helped me a ton like oh i'm not alone oh
there's a bunch of people out there that
can relate
oh by me sharing this person is going to
get tested next week because they have
cancer in their family and that's the
message that like i really try to hit
home on my instagram um
is that yo
doctors work for us yeah and i think a
lot of people forget that and i've had
women tell me like my doctor says i
don't need to get tested until i'm 35.
i'm like [ __ ] that
find a new doctor
get help because that's not that's not
acceptable yeah so you're saying your
doctor should always try to really um
encourage whatever curiosity you have
absolutely got it 100 i also think uh so
like gsp one of my favorite mma fighters
i think he said it best too i think a
lot of people they put the knowledge and
expertise and decision making in the
authority the gsp what he says he goes
you have to be your first mma coach yeah
you're the first mma coach and yes you
have a head mma coach but you need to
know what you need you want to get out
of it so you pick the right one and
you're hiring the right one and i think
that applies to everything else like you
have to be your own mechanic first
rather than just going to a random shop
and then they mess up your car and you
blame it on them it's like no you're
your first mechanic did you do your due
diligence and i think you have to be
your own first doctor before you hire a
doctor yeah and then and that's what
i'll say to be your own advocate yeah
and
uh it's it's such a bummer hearing those
stories about people that were denied
testing or like no you don't have to
worry about it like
i'm sorry why isn't everyone tested
like like it should just be like a
general a general thing yeah like you're
getting our our flu shot or whatever
like every year we need to get these
things yeah or one of them or you know
just everyone's tested at i don't know
13 14 before you start having children
yeah so you can make educated decisions
whether you feel like passing that on or
not yeah because it's a 50 50 chance
right
so
i to me i'm just like this is so obvious
why don't why don't we do it like this
yeah um so it's not for people that just
are not exposed to it it's a bummer here
i had no idea about that like in my
family we don't have any of that stuff
that at least that i'm aware of um i
really don't know much about my body
honestly because it's just like it was
never really emphasized or if it was i'd
missed school that day or something sure
like in my household it's more about
like let's survive we're immigrants to
this country let's get [ __ ] like you
say pitter-patter let's move your
pattern um so
taking care of your general health is
not a thing yeah it's like it's not a
thing until there's a thing right and
now you're like [ __ ] mm-hmm i think also
like going back to what you said but
it's like just um you know blatantly
trusting these doctors as authority
figures can also be such a generational
thing like for our parents i feel like
that is that's the law that's the word
like there's no second opinions there's
no
maybe more holistic care or alternative
care you know every everything that
we're seeing now with
incredible advancements in like plant
medicine and stuff like our parents are
are just not open you know absolutely
not and um i think that's a thing that's
changing and it's really cool because
people are being their own advocates
like they're going and it can be
overwhelming looking at all the research
and other things that are out there
where do you even start yeah um
i've been very lucky in that aspect to
also you know have my sister kind of
guide this because i didn't know this
uh genetic mutation was a thing until
she's like hey this exists we should get
tested damn good for her and not
everyone has that person in their life
and i'm like wow now i can do that with
my audience i love that so i was super
super open about the whole recovery
process the whole rehab process getting
back to lifting um you know sharing like
my mobility i'm like here's how far i
can reach today and today i'm here and
you know like the whole process
uh
so it was it was great it felt good
sharing that and you know there was a
great response to that too people are oh
my god thank you i didn't know this was
a thing uh my mom had breast cancer me
and my sister are gonna go get tested
and to me that's that's everything yeah
that's all that matters it's like
oh i wanted to make a difference now i
am like maybe i didn't feel like i was
back then yeah like yo you're really
making a difference these people could
be saving their own lives absolutely
when did you know at what age or at what
point in your life did you know that you
wanted to make a difference um
i think probably
when i was diagnosed but i didn't know
how gotcha i knew that i didn't feel
like i was making a difference currently
i knew that i felt it a little bit with
coaching and in the gym and helping
these people make these positive changes
in their lives and with their body and
their health you didn't feel like you're
making a difference there no i did i did
not not in my uh not in my corporate
position oh i see yeah so so i was kind
of headed down that route but didn't
really know like what is that thing yeah
and and then i was diagnosed i was like
oh i have a thing [ __ ] this and i'm like
wait
let's spin this around like this could
be a really really impactful you know
thing that you have to share with the
world super cool
um that's what you said about my nickel
allergies
super cool
hey i'm very positive you're so positive
that's why i love you thank you uh so i
want to backtrack a little bit because
you keep talking we just covered so much
yeah we did we absolutely went on the
deep end really quickly um but just to
backtrack a little bit you keep saying
you're an athlete right yeah i called
you a coach yeah you are competi you do
compete in powerlifting but before that
even happened you were uh track and
field in college in college yeah i ran
track yeah um and then from that
i mean i can understand the transition
from going to that to now the real world
and going okay i got to make a living
so they went to that yeah um and i was
working in that position part-time in
college i was already working for
victoria's secret and just stayed with
them and was working my way up you know
into like a supervisor role and a
manager and so on and so on and was that
because you're like well that's the safe
route to take i never thought of it as
being safe um i thought of it as
something i enjoyed at the time gotcha
and something i was good at
and then i never
coaching kind of
fell into my lap gotcha how did it
realize that i really enjoyed it so my
friend owned a crossfit gym at the time
and i was
kind of training more than i should at
that point in my life i was like
crossfit in the morning and like still
bodybuilding um but they were looking
for trainers to be at the gym and so i
got certified and started taking clients
there part time while still working at
victoria's secret yeah
okay i remember your question certified
as in like getting your level one and
then teaching crossfit oh no not
crossfit certified in like uh personal
training oh i see yes yes and then i
found powerlifting okay how did you find
that my friend who was a crossfit
competitor told me that she was signing
up for a power of team meet and i'm like
oh what's that what year are we talking
2015.
2014 yeah and i was like what's that and
she's like what's this it's squat bench
deadlift i'm like that's it you know
that's it you just have to lift heavy
you're doing those three already uh
squatting and dead lifting but you don't
bench so much in crosstalk right yeah i
mean occasionally but not time and then
you were doing bodybuilding
yeah still not benching a ton yeah and
not doing it properly not in like a
powerlifting way right yeah
um so i jumped into that meet with her
with like maybe three months a kind of
serious training um i won my weight
class and i was like yeah this is
definitely what did you win with what
are the numbers my numbers um i think
like a 2 30 squat nice damn that's
pretty in 2014 2015 that was [ __ ] no
one really in in wraps too because i
didn't know what i was doing so i had to
coach them
crazy so probably actually squatting
like two hundred maybe two that's still
really good for that time and i was
competition first
yeah and i was probably like 115.
just just a skinny kid yeah um
bench maybe 120 125. that's really good
then and then pulled like 286. damn it
all good
it was good enough to win my weight
class at that meet at that point in time
and um i was telling bart like now i
look at my best numbers and i'm like yo
those don't even they don't want to try
to do [ __ ] anymore yeah um the
competition is crazy it's cool it's so
cool to see women you know deadlifting
over 600 like benching well over three
am i squatting four hundred pounds like
nothing it's very disgusting
no they need to stop they need to stop
it's very very discouraging
i look at the girls
in my weight class and they're stronger
than me dude and it's all because of
social media social media is just
attracting this higher caliber athlete
and and
it's
available yeah more people can find the
sport yeah and you don't need a lot of
equipment to do this sport right i need
gym membership and
belt you know wrist straps that's it um
but so i did my first power to me and
after that i was hooked so i got my
power lifting um like level one cert
and focused on taking power lifting
clients and i had some lifestyle clients
too i had like a couple grandmas in
their 60s oh cool that always kept
training interesting because i'm like
okay i have a group of athletes and then
i have you know this grandma that wants
to hatred her goal is like carry her
grandchildren up the stairs
you know so that was dope like just a
really wide variety of people with
different goals always kept me on my
toes um and challenged as a coach which
was cool so
how did you know you wanted that to be
like once you figured out you're not
gonna do what your typical nine-to-five
was how did you know that a coaching was
gonna be it
because that's where i was finding joy
in my life yeah so i put my two weeks in
and then i announced that i was gonna
start taking people at this gym and
contact me here where did you put that
up uh on the internet i had a bit of a
following at the time i was talking
about um maybe 20
30k how did you how did you how did you
get there how did you start even posting
on instagram and getting a following
just by lifting videos
so you were just a [ __ ] stud and i
was just sharing sharing lifting videos
and sharing my life and that kind of
like part-time coach trainer life in the
gym and it kind of grew organically and
it was so
much easier to grow organically back
then yeah you know so that wasn't
unheard of but so i already had a little
bit of a following started advertising
and i got enough people to where i was
like almost making the same amount as i
was there and um or at my corporate job
and put in my two weeks you know didn't
burn any of those bridges even though i
was tempted to
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] you like yeah one of
those things um
and then yeah just started living my
life in the gym all day every day
training people doing my own workouts
and it eventually got to a point where
i was a bit burnt out like i i overdid
it i didn't want to stay and do my own
workouts
and i was like okay this is kind of the
opposite of what i wanted to happen what
was driving you at that point was it
financial stability or was it help as
many people as possible or was it like i
don't know both both definitely the
financial stability piece because i was
trying to you know i was making good
money before and then you're like oh now
it's all up to me i need to buy my own
health insurance i need to do all these
self-employment things that uh equal
expenses right
so definitely financial and i'm like
okay i can cram this many sessions in a
day but then when i'm all done
i don't want to do my own training
there's only so many hours in a day
there's only so many clients i can see
okay how do i scale this
right so that was when i
actually moved to st louis and decided
to from iowa from iowa yeah the quad
cities in iowa
and when i moved
i was gonna move in with a friend
and kind of just figure my life out and
when i moved i said okay i'm gonna just
take people online wait sorry wait why
st louis you could have gone to l.a i
could have gone anywhere right capitals
of my kindness i was in a i had just
left a really shitty relationship and i
needed a quick out
and i had a friend in st louis that i
could caught him in with yeah she had a
spare bedroom i was like yo can i'm
moving with you until i figure this out
she's amazing we're still good friends
she's like of course
so when i moved to st louis i was like
okay i'm gonna switch to online only see
if i can make this work if i can't i
know there's a gym that would take me as
a trainer it's a safe fall back right
nice so i
online for you was like this is i can
scale i'm not going to be burnt out i
can do right right i can handle
30 40 clients instead of you know 10 15.
did anyone walk you through this before
or were you looking at other people's
models and going oh that's what they're
doing i think i can make it work yeah
basically uh okay i'll send you
programming you send me videos i'll give
you feedback where i'm charging less
than i would in person of course um and
fingers crossed let's see if i can make
this work i see other people on
instagram doing the online coaching
thing i think this seems possible taking
that leap of faith though is so crazy
you know because like yeah
i've taken it twice now so i'm like what
did it i left a thing before and i made
it work i think i can do this again
but yeah because there's always that
fear of unknown oh yeah it's like if you
work for a company i'm like well you
know i will work for
i don't know like spectrum and you're
like they're probably going to be around
so my job would probably be around yeah
this is stable this is a safe versus
when you're working for yourself you're
like i don't even know if i'm gonna be
around so you're like who knows you know
that's crazy i'm definitely one of those
people though that like
i will stay comfortable
until i just force myself to jump
like i'll jump and catch myself and
figure it out but otherwise i'll just
chill so i always have to kind of be
like pushing myself to get uncomfortable
right yeah that makes sense absolutely
absolutely so you're just challenging
yourself like i'll jump and i'll figure
it out and i'll make it work yeah but if
i don't do that i'll just sit back and
just like coast and you don't like that
and i'm not that big of a fan of that
part of my personality right as soon as
i feel that something's calling me to
jump i have to do it yeah yeah cause i
just realized um i think there shouldn't
ever be a
aversion to something and if there is i
think it's actually your ego hiding an
insecurity yeah and so you start coming
up with like
excuses you're like oh you don't need to
do that because of this oh yeah because
of that but that's where the growth is
going to happen on the other side so as
soon as i feel it i'm like i have to do
it
and it's so cliche that growth and
change all happens outside of your
comfort zone yeah well that's dead on
yeah yeah that's very true and so many
things can stop you from taking that
first step like you said even that like
imposter syndrome
like who am i that people would want
this from me all the time would they
listen to me
yeah in
any any way well because
absolute um uh
opposite of that is you kind of have to
be a little narcissistic that you have
to have this confidence and like yeah i
am kind of the [ __ ] and you should be
listening to me you know
i get it i mean we're all operating on
the most
narcissistic app
true that has ever existed true yeah
from one follower to a
you're taking a picture of yourself
that's
look at me yeah yeah the whole thing
look at me look what i can do it's very
very interesting like social experiment
yeah um but yeah i knew that i had to
jump and figure it out and it helps to
know that like okay if it doesn't here's
what i can do and
you know i appreciate my parents like
any time i made a weird move or you know
in my career or physically moved they're
like it's fine you can always go back to
what you're doing you always come back
home that's amazing and i think my
parents um
maybe they haven't always understood but
they've always supported that's
beautiful i came to all my track meets
came to all my powerlifting means like
yeah they're great what was your event
in track by the way the 400 the 400 yeah
that's just one lapse right just one
line one big round left one look how he
just minimized that [ __ ] no just a
little better one time around right no i
didn't mean like that no because i was
like i forgot if it was 200.
yeah 200 is half so even like looking at
a track now i'm like oh how did you get
around that in less than a minute like
it just makes me want to puke just
thinking you didn't less than a minute
was your fastest 59 seconds oh yeah it's
just it's a sprint it's consistent what
made you do 400 versus 200 or the 100
that was my best event like i was most
competitive
in that so a track meet for me was
always the open four the four by four
and the four by one because i was like
the third or fourth one hundredth
fastest girl what's four by four like a
relay yes so every person runs one lap
you have a baton yeah right you pass it
off every person completes a lap have
you ever done hurdles absolutely not
i'm not like this you know tall
beautiful six foot goddess here yeah she
jumps over two hurdles at a time
yeah she's tall her i'm like a [ __ ]
giraffe dude i have none of that in me
dude we're just tall but we're not
efficient
and i love track like for me track was
like the end all be all until i found
lifting i was like well i'm actually
much better at this much more
competitive yeah even though i'm not
really built i feel like to do either of
those things particularly well your
bench is really good for someone with
long arms why are they so long i'm just
gumby i don't even know that they're
like i didn't really realize
i could wrap you both up in the most
perfect hug
right now um
yeah i don't know where we were in my
store no i online
um okay so at this point uh are you a
sponsored athlete and a coach and like
you're kind of traveling everywhere are
we not there yet um i think the
sponsorships were kind of just slowly
starting to roll in yeah i worked with a
local clothing company before i moved to
st louis um
when i moved to st louis i got on with
run everything labs supplements that's
robin dana's yes yes and i would have
gotten on
with matt's company haper and goods
probably right before i moved to st
louis so they were kind of just starting
to slow roll in as my following was
growing and
that was kind of developing were you
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna make a living off
of this or is this one of those moments
where you're like or off of this meaning
um off of the internet social media
instagram or were you like i don't know
what's happening i'm still rolling and
leaning into it let's figure it out as
we go uh i would say probably the latter
i think my whole life has kind of been
like a figuring it out oh [ __ ] she's
like yeah she wasn't even that strategic
you weren't like i'm growing at this
rate i know i'm gonna i need a network i
know i have to do all this stuff i don't
think i've done a lot of things
strategically
that's amazing like i feel like i do now
a bit more so it sounds like you do a
lot of that yeah yeah and i think now
there's a lot more thought put into it
and
you know realizing your value and your
worth and like things to ask for as far
as sponsorship sponsorships and like
what's a monthly salary like what's
reasonable for that um but at the time
and when you're starting off i think
you're taking what you can get you know
you're like oh cool this company sent me
free products and a hundred dollars a
month amazing you know what i mean yeah
um so just kind of figuring it out and
you know watching other people
and like oh people are making this work
like i don't need to go anywhere for
work every day and i remember that being
a really weird thing when i was like i
don't have an office to i have to go to
i don't have to go to a gym to see
clients yeah you don't technically have
to dress up odd yeah very odd um or wake
up at like work time you don't yeah
right
if you think about it we've been
programmed since we were five to have a
schedule clock in clock out
have a lunch hour at this time and then
there's a cut off at three whether
that's school or for sports or uh
working at a nine to five yeah yeah
we've been programmed today and i
actually like that yeah having that
schedule yeah it makes me the most
productive which is why
even when we started working for
ourselves i just stuck to a schedule
yeah yeah and for some people like
that's that's a must like that's a must
it makes you most productive that works
really well um for me when i was just
starting off and building clients there
were definitely days where i'm like i
don't know what to do with all this free
time i have because i check in with
these clients twice a week
i've got free time like all i need to do
is watch some videos and have some
communication you know so for me it was
like what do i even do with all this
time i have is kind of odd yeah um
but yeah i was i was getting on with
sponsors i flew out for a couple of your
guys's uh photo shoots yeah i feel like
it's strange that we've known each other
for this long but like
we're really getting to know each other
this year yeah this year started off
with a bang yeah and it's just was it
just this year yeah oh january 1st so
yeah yeah
or two days into last year
it was 2020 going into 2021 yeah so um i
actually didn't get to meet you during
that time because i was either pregnant
or i had just given birth so i was
completely out of barbell i think we had
met once or twice but i had i'd run into
bart more often yeah where did we meet
maybe at an event arnold olympia maybe
fit expo i came with matt to
your studio when y'all podcasted with
matt one time okay the one in l.a and
that might have been the one time that
we met i do remember that and it was so
brief
tacos in the back from a taco truck no
no no they just came and went we didn't
even we didn't even do dinner it was it
was just in and out for he was on the
podcast with y'all yeah i think and that
was like
i think so and that was the only time we
had met i think we had met twice maybe
prior to that but yeah this this year
just changed everything i'm so grateful
for that absolutely oh my god okay so i
hate it because i'm looking at the clock
and i'm like oh [ __ ] we're running out
of time um but i do want to get into
something that i think is so interesting
um
the fact that so so you started pretty
traditionally i would say right like you
went to school you did athletics yes um
you ended up doing nine to five climbing
the corporate ladder i think that's very
traditional that's very normal we can
all wrap our brains around that um then
you stumble across or not i don't know
if you stumbled across it but um you do
powerlifting your social media starts
growing you're like oh [ __ ] life changes
flipping it all around um i'm going to
start doing my own thing you find out
you have um the braca
that would have been after after before
before before oh before right okay so
you have that that puts that i was like
definitely the catalyst to leave my my
nine to five yeah so that puts kind of a
fire on your ass
uh to be like oh [ __ ] i gotta figure
this [ __ ] out because time is of the
essence
um
but then
you try you i don't know if at this
point or any of
this these phases in your life you
started looking to like alternative
medicine aka
uh drugs mm-hmm right okay drugs aka
drugs
that's funny why is it funny no i just i
just jumped right in i'm tired looking
for a euphemism but it wasn't if you
want a nicer term you can say plant
medicine medicine yeah aka the hard
stuff
um
what what was it was that something that
you were like leaning into because you
wanted to sort some [ __ ] out or was it
like it was something you did for
funsies that kind of turn into and
specifically what plant medicine sure so
i think um
it's it started you know smoking weed
which is pretty casual i never
uh smoked with much intention other than
like relax sleep get a little loose
laugh feel good yeah like a glass of
wine after dinner or something yeah like
very casual not a lot of intention or
expectation behind it and then it would
have been in 2019 so matt and i um are
together neither of us drink really at
all anymore maybe one here and there um
but smoking weed pretty regularly
together like that's our nighttime down
regulation routine like we love doing
that together we love getting silly
y'all see us yeah
just being goofy and flirty love it
so in 2019 some my camera was um but a
friend of matt's matz
connected matt to this place called
rhythmia which is a holistic healing
center in costa rica and their whole
kind of
their whole thing is
giving these ayahuasca experiences to
people and they were looking for
influencers and
yes who were interested who felt called
to the medicine
and they were looking for people to come
down and come down for a week of
ceremony and
be fully transparent and 100 open about
their experience while it really means
i'm scared terrified because like when
you have a uh i think that the worst
nightmare for like an influencer or
someone with the following
is
being in your vulnerable most vulnerable
state right and you're like
like that well i didn't have my phone on
me in the ceremony but oh okay but then
like other people that recognize you and
then you know it's like imagine like you
catch will smith like
on the grass somewhere oh my god is that
will smith
[Applause]
um i was not concerned about anyone
recognizing me there
uh i knew it would be a completely
different crowd yeah than the than the
bubble that the strength world that
we're used to operating in um matt and i
were very out of place there we're just
like very much these like derpy kind of
meatheads
really we looked very out of place
people
remembered our names instantly because
we were just so like didn't look like we
were meant to be there yeah um
i think about like
the kookiest uh
yoga person you know like and then
that's you dude and then imagine
and then imagine a hundred it's
interesting that you say that because
depending on what kind of friends friend
group we're in were either like the
super kooky kind of spiritual ones or
were the meat heads i get it okay so for
some
reason we're able to like float back
between these two worlds which is super
cool and i'm very grateful for it but in
this situation we were the meatheads
right
just looked ridiculous there there was
probably no other guys over 150 pounds
okay so like yeah
um
i could relate to because in the comedy
world everyone looks at me like i'm the
rock sure but in the fitness world i'm
like i'm the smallest guy i know right
right and that's
that too some people like oh my god matt
and he's like what are you talking about
like my brother's 6 5 300 you know so
yeah it's all
relative yeah um so matt had been very
interested in ayahuasca
and everything he had read about it and
you know podcasts and heard about it
and me it was it was a bit of a newer
concept so i started kind of diving into
that and thinking about you know what
would i like to get out of it and then
you know rhythmia was like yeah we'd
love to have you guys come down share
your week share your experience you know
we'd like to see a couple posts and we'd
like you to read this book before you
come and share the book and
so it was really well done really uh
organized and
we get there on a sunday and there's um
ceremony monday tuesday wednesday
thursday night so it's four ayahuasca
four days in a row it's four nights in a
row
it's a very exhausting week so
ceremony starts at 5 30 in the evening
you go to the maloka the temple in the
center of the resort and it kind of
feels like an all-inclusive nice resort
but then there's also a bit that like
makes it feel like kind of a rehab
facility like you're like okay something
else is
happening here this is not just
relaxation
no oh but it just has a different energy
vibe
like you know people are there
for some
something else other than just relaxing
other than vacation yeah yeah it's it's
not a drug like a party drug like this
is work this is medicine
um so yeah you're there for four nights
of ceremony so uh
it starts at 5 30 and it usually goes
until about 2 pm or 2 a.m pardon me oh
my god yeah
so there's tripping balls for [ __ ]
like seven hours some nights
um and there's no dinner so
because typically people get sick and
purge
um purge purge which is that was one
thing that i think a lot of people come
into really scared of like oh i'm going
to throw up in front of all these people
exactly i don't want to be will smith
[ __ ] throw all the places
like a [ __ ] cat bringing up a [ __ ]
hairball
yeah
yeah
and what's coming is going right so
whatever you're feeling is exactly what
you need to feel and get rid of um but
so there was a hundred people there that
week and
can you walk me through your first trip
and want to what does it feel like the
minute you recognize how much time do we
have the minute you recognize that your
mind is in an alternative time so let me
set the scene for you okay um so the
maloca is this temple in the middle of
the resort and it's just this big kind
of open-air room and there are twin
hundred twin mattresses all laid out yep
there's a hundred people there
um are they at least nice mattresses or
do they look like jail like
it looks nice it looks good yeah memory
foam or coils
probably memory foam
everything looked very nice there was
nothing sketchy at all um mattress
pillow blanket bucket toilet paper
that's what you have tight there are
bathrooms um the bucket is for vomiting
not taking a [ __ ] yeah i suppose you
could have you had but that's never an
issue getting to the bathroom so you go
in for ceremony 5 30 you um are
encouraged to dress in all white just
out of respect for aya um were you
nervous already like does it feel like
you're doing it you're about to be
terrified because i had no idea what to
expect up until
um ayahuasca i had only done mushrooms a
couple times yeah so my
experience with psychedelics was
pretty little um but those had all been
good experiences and really eye opening
for me and so i was already kind of
headed down that path which is great but
when you're doing these things it's
always for self-work
or is it just like to have fun
i've done both tight i've done both um i
think both are perfectly fine
um and i think more drugs are suited to
one and more drugs are suited to the
other two but so you go to ceremony you
get your cup and so ayahuasca is like a
thick brewed tea
so it's not a nice texture it's not a
nice flavor but it's like a tall shot
it's like a chowder almost yeah not like
chunky i see but it's just thick
um take it like a shot um as you get
your
drink the shaman in front of you and
there's multiple shaman in the building
and they're there to hold space and
protect the energy and help anyone that
needs help throughout the night
in no matter what that means right
so you go up to the shaman you get your
cup
and you kind of just put your intentions
into the drink and like what you'd like
to get out of your evening and what
you'd like to get out of ceremony take a
drink go back to
well i guess you don't go back to your
mattress just yet you go to another
shaman who gives you pape which is a
tobacco mixed with tree ash or tree bark
ash and that is a little pipe and it
goes into your into your nostril and
then go and it blows into your head what
does that do
uh it's like an instant drunk is the
best way i would describe it
and i had some nights where it was
really intense and really why do they do
that
it's just to enhance your experience
and there's a lot of ceremony and uh
routine
culture that goes into that as well
but the best way i can describe the prop
is like an instant drunk like you go to
completely sober to feeling like oh i
had 15 beers holy [ __ ]
and that's a that's a good solid blow
like it's like back your brains kind of
whoa go out
um
or you can have a gentle one that's like
okay i'm a little [ __ ] up but i'm fine
i can get back to my mattress um so the
first two nights of ceremony i had
nothing
absolutely nothing i didn't have any
visions
i didn't you didn't even feel like the
altar
no
what nothing so a lot like that first
night i stayed in my mattress the second
night i went outside and i laid in the
hammock and i watched the stars it was
actually new year's eve so i was
watching the fireworks going off and
that was pretty cool
um but yeah had nadas for the first two
nights were you like this shit's [ __ ]
weak
um i was a little suspicious
at that point because i came in fairly
skeptical you know i'm like oh is matt
tripping balls at this point uh he also
had nadas the first two nights nadas are
you speaking spanish nadas like nothing
nada oh okay that's not sure okay got it
yeah nothing happened so both of you
guys drank the ayahuasca
nothing for two nights nothing the first
two nights of ceremony so and we
podcasted the whole time we're down
there so we podcast every morning and
talk about our night before cool so the
podcast of of the after the second night
of ceremony
excuse me it's probably a really big
bummer to listen to because we were both
bummed and matt was so frustrated sleep
deprived yeah because he he came in with
so many things that he wanted out of the
experience he has very specific
intentions which
you know it gives you what you what you
need not necessarily what you want right
so that's why i think it maybe could
have gotten tricky for him so okay those
were the first two nights night number
three was ladies night so all the women
were shaman or all the shaman were women
that night
and they have um
live music and drums and flutes and just
really beautiful
tribal music playing and there's just
incense and candles and my contacts are
out because so i'm kind of blind and
it's all just very
very trippy
um so i get my drink i get my hot bay
and i go
lay down on my mattress and i'm like
okay if nothing else like maybe i'll get
a good night's sleep you know
based off the first two nights and so
i'm laying there in fetal position
i remember very specifically i'm on my
uh right side
and i'm just kind of relaxing and then
all of a sudden i feel like these waves
kind of just rolling through me like
just kind of energy coursing through me
i'm like okay here we go like i i'm
familiar enough in these waters that i
recognize this feeling but our seat
belts yeah i'm like okay
i'm like something's happening tonight
i'm like great let's go this is why i
came here put the football helmet on
yeah
and um
i hope i have enough time to talk about
all this no
it's kind of a if you really want me to
break it down i will yeah no um it's
crazy so i'm laying there very
interested i'm feeling all this energy
kind of just rolling through me and i'm
laying there and right here in my vision
my eyes are closed but um this girl
appears to me and she's a sketch it's
like a pencil sketch like like a [ __ ]
like what's that [ __ ] take on me
music video or something like that i
don't know hey
no okay never mind move it i don't know
but a pencil sketch pencil sketch of a
little girl little girl not a lady
little girl and she goes how can i help
ah
and i'm like oh [ __ ] and before i could
respond to her she's gone she disappears
that was just it was how can i help and
i'm like whoa
and then i'm kind of like oh
interesting i sit up and i look around
and i'm instantly just overcome with so
much fear and anxiety
i'm just terrified
and so i can't see that well it's dark
it's smoky and then i'm kind of just
taking in the scene around me and i'm
like
oh my god we're all crazy like i felt
like we were in like an insane asylum
like there's a ton of beds crazy here
yeah
and
there's a girl who can't like walk she's
drunk you know drunk on aya and she's
like slow motion like army crawling oh
jesus that's like
there's a guy over here who spoke in
tongues every night and he was over
there doing his
tongues thing
um there's one lady over here just
aggressively rocking herself and then to
top it all off to add to my fear
there was a girl
outside
screaming oh my to be killed
oh my god um and all the
shaman had left
the maloca they'd all ran outside to
help this girl and i'm just overcome
with fear like i just can't stop crying
it's nowhere to be found he's in boys
matt is actually on the other side of
the maloccas they encourage you to split
up from your partner that way you're not
impacted by their night yeah because
whatever you're feeling and experiencing
could be completely opposite of what
they're feeling and experiencing they
don't want you distracted by trying to
assist your partner yeah so i'm
terrified i'm crying i'm like it's like
like that kind of crying and i'm
self-soothing with that rocking motion
which i don't know that i've ever done
in my life yeah maybe i did it as a
child
um but i'm just using that self-suit and
i'm crying and rocking and sobbing and
so afraid and afraid that he's afraid
i'm worried about him i'm thinking about
him
um
and eventually like i i
no one comes to help me like no one
comes no shaman comes
none of my neighbors
help me
nothing
and it's exactly what i needed
i needed to be able to get over that
fear and conquer that fear by myself
and all i wanted was for someone to come
like tell me like touch me and tell me
it was gonna be okay
and no one ever came
and once i kind of had a grip on that
and i understood
why i needed to experience it alone i
was like okay
let me gather myself
i think i have to go to the bathroom
i think i can feel my bladder and i
think i need to pee
and so you're very just unsure of your
body like if i stand up can i is that
gonna work like will my legs work and so
i stood up and i'm like oh okay all good
so i make it to the bathroom which is
not very far so your high as [ __ ] then
you are but you also know you are
like uh you're like okay there's a
reason i feel this way yes because i
took a drug yeah um so you're not so out
of touch to where you aren't like able
to like
rationalize you know what i mean yeah
yeah um so i get up about the bathroom
i'm sitting in the bathroom and it's the
most impactful bathroom moment i've ever
had in my life i'm sitting in there i'm
like
okay you were sober enough to come here
so that means you're sober enough to go
get a second drink
and that's the second drink like a
second shot what made you want to get a
second shot they say if you are like
feeling sober enough to where you can
handle it you should do it oh and i'm
like okay
i don't want to but i know i should so i
mustered up my courage and i went up you
know back to the front and got my next
drink from the shaman
and i thought i was going to be sick for
that when i kind of scurried back to my
mattress because i thought i was going
to puke but i didn't um i got back and
then the fear just came all over again
i'm crying i'm sobbing i'm rocking just
aggressively still no one's coming still
no one's coming no comfort nothing um
and i remember you know what i told you
like everything i'm feeling like what's
coming is going i'm supposed to feel
this i'm supposed to feel this fear i'm
supposed to process this fear
for whatever reason i have all this fear
built up inside of me and i just need to
let it go
and so i got to a good point with it and
then the music changed and for whatever
reason that music shifting it shifted
over to like a really um
like kind of tribal drums
and it was really really good like i
felt it
i felt it and like i felt very seen by
the music
and
i was like
oh and then all of a sudden everything
started feeling really really really
good
and my fingertips were just buzzing
with electricity and like i was like
feeling my body and i'm like
whoa just completely overwhelmed by my
own body and what an amazing like were
you like capable machine [ __ ] jack oh
dope i wasn't even thinking jack but i
kept like squeezing my butt i'm like
this is incredible
i was like oh my god
um
close my eyes would close my eyes and
see these beautiful just kaleidoscopes
and just blasting through this
incredible
um amount of like sacred geometry and
just
it was beautiful and it was happening
when my eyes were open and it was
happening my eyes were closed and when i
closed my eyes i would i couldn't just i
couldn't help but giggle and so
i'm giggling and then this guy over here
would be giggling and i we just go back
and forth and they say no crosstalk
right like you can puke you can cough
you can cry laugh whatever you need to
do but like no talking and me and this
guy is going back and forth and i'm just
being like this little kid just like she
couldn't greet each other right
and um my neighbor this lovely lady from
australia was having it look like she
was having a beautiful night because she
was kind of laying there and just
dancing and just her hands were just
moving and it was so beautiful and i
just got locked in on her hands and i
watched him for a while and then i like
put my hands in with hers and were just
vibing and she's touching my arms i'm
touching her arms and it was
not sexual at all but just this amazing
connection
she told me the next morning at
breakfast that i had become her daughter
oh yeah which was really meaningful her
for her because she hasn't had any
relationship with her daughter for so
long
and so we're vibing and just having a
beautiful night and i'm just giggling
and just completely blissed out like to
the max
and then one of the shaman came over and
she just to check on me
and i'm like crying laughing because i
cannot keep my [ __ ] together you've seen
it i just can't stop yeah um and she
would pass my back and guys i'm back and
she's like how are you doing i'm like i
get it i was like this is what i've been
missing you know because my first two
nights have been nothing and um she just
like gave me a hug and then left you
know go check on someone else
and you're like where were you the other
[ __ ] two hours you [ __ ]
but man it's it's exactly what i needed
yeah no i get it yeah do you have any
questions like longing questions
answered um not that night i don't think
um i think that night was
aya
just showing me both ends of the
spectrum
like it's like extreme fear darkness and
lightness like this is how gnarly this
can get and this is how dark and scary
and ugly this can get and this is how
incredibly beautiful and blissed out
this can be for you wow um
so i think i have a lot more
work to do the next time i feel called
to ceremony but um i i stayed in that
blissed out stink probably until like
5am
um
bless matt's heart because he had a more
chill night all of his nights were
pretty chill compared to mine um but he
just let me touch him and feel his body
and
cry over how beautiful his elbows were
and play with his hair and just be
completely overwhelmed by his existence
and just let me giggle until 5am and
held my hand and let me just cry at the
stars
and um
it was
that was the the women's night or the
ladies night night three that was my my
really really big
impactful night really what did you take
away from that i think i think just
being able to let go of the fear was so
so important for me um because i think
that that fear had actually been a block
the first two nights just just because i
was so afraid of what could happen do
you think just the unknown of it do you
think that was also something that you
carried with you because i think at this
point you hadn't
um
come to terms yet with
you know having to remove your boobs or
like that vision right very true no no
this would this would have been like a
year a year before i decided to make
that decision um and i left with letting
go of so much fear and anxiety and i
also left with tons of
gratitude and appreciation for my body
that's what it seemed like does it seem
like you're in
overwhelmed by
myself yeah that's so cool by this
avatar meat sack that i'm cruising
around in i love the meat sack
it's incredible right like just
being so grateful for it and everything
it's done for me that's so interesting
because right when you when he was
asking like what wait what is bracca
what are you talking about that you were
just so pissed at your body yeah like
why is this [ __ ] turning on me yeah oh
i'm so far from that yeah and even
throughout the healing process after
surgery i'm continually just amazed by
this like our ability to heal and
recover from these incredibly traumatic
things yeah and you know that was a lot
of what matt experienced too with his
nine surgeries like he had some talking
to do to his hip and knee and his body
and like your your
body your muscles
it remembers all this trauma you not
might not remember because you're under
anesthesia right that's the whole point
but it's still happening to your body
your body's still
absorbing all this trauma
and that has to be
released somehow right or or come to
terms with somehow because it's holding
on to this energy
so that was really impactful for him and
for me waking up the next morning
was
so insane because everything about me
was perfect
my skin was perfect my hair was perfect
i was literally glowing
and it didn't feel like it was in my
head like to the touch i'm like oh my
god i'm like a newborn baby
it was insane and everyone knew um
not that they had seen me but like when
i came to breakfast like everyone could
tell
and everyone's like so how was your
night i was like well pretty good i give
them a little run down and they're like
well happy birthday oh
and it just felt so good and i met the
guy that i was giggling back and forth
with last night and he's like you were
so great he's like your energy was so
good he's like you were just like a
little kid that had a secret
i'm like that sounds about right because
i was just snickering all night like
this is so trippy this is so cool um
but that next morning was
one of the best mornings ever was just
my favorite cause i'm like oh my god
like everything about me is perfect
how cool and it wasn't even in like some
type of weird narcissistic way but like
i genuinely felt i genuinely believed it
just being grateful for yourself wow
that's awesome to the next level have
you ever had that before no not like
that not like that no and i was more
like performance or numbers or
placements i've generally had a pretty
good relationship with myself and my
appearance and my body and i'm very
grateful for that and everything that
has led to that um
but never never like this yeah it was
something completely different and just
to experience that level of bliss it's
like oh that exists
i know that that level
exists somewhere and i just feel like i
got a taste of it i wish everyone can
experience that
because i think no matter
what shape or look or whatever that
people have
the first thing that people look for is
what's not good enough you know the 63
guy is like i wish i was 6'5 or the guy
that's twelve percent body fat is like i
wish i was ten percent you know like
even the most beautiful person that's
like oh my i wish my eyebrow was like
this and it's like you'll you'll never
have
you can never yeah you can never be
perfect enough yeah right but being able
to like how about like let's put this in
reverse
and how about let's just be extremely
grateful and find beauty in what we have
wow you know and just being at that
bliss state with whatever you have
that'd be so awesome yeah yeah it was
it was incredible i definitely wouldn't
have changed a thing and even looking
back on pictures from that week and that
trip and
we stayed a couple extra days at an
airbnb just to kind of
integrate everything before we head back
to airport in reality even just looking
back on pictures of that in those days
i'm like oh yeah i can see that i can
see that glow and it's it's such a
bummer that i couldn't hang on to that
forever but it was one of those things
that kind of just dwindled away it
wasn't like a quick off yeah um
but it's just kind of less and less and
one of my favorite things about that
week was
they have the ceremonies at night right
and then you have breakfast with
everyone then there's usually like a
yoga and a breath work class
and then in the afternoon from like one
to three there's an integration class so
everyone gets to share if they want
their experience from the night before
and
uh matt and i quickly learned that we
were there where we were people that
were there with very little trauma in
our lives
um people are there to deal with some
very heavy heavy things
very dark things rape abuse
addiction things like that yeah and
we're like okay we are
very blessed and very grateful to you
know have these childhoods that we did
and
you know to to be starting
ahead maybe more than others in life
like that's something we need to
always
always keep in perspective and stay in a
gratitude mindset about
but all these integration classes were
so wonderful because they're like okay
here's what you experienced
um
what are the pieces of that that you
want to take home what are the pieces of
that that you want to integrate into
your normal life how are you going to
take this experience and not go back to
your old habits your old ways super cool
um so it's not just uh here you're going
to trip here you're going to trip on
later good luck like it's very very
helpful
um and like we talked about uh the weed
thing are you using it to connect or
disconnect that was something that they
brought up in one of those integration
classes um so how are you gonna use your
experience to change your life and some
people are like
in ceremony last night i realized that
my calling is to open a book shop so i'm
going to go home and open a bookshop wow
and people would have very direct
downloads like that of like i should be
doing x and i'm not so as soon as i get
back that's not good i'm going this
route with my life um
it's interesting the things that uh will
show up that will be the same so there's
these things called celestial surgeons
and this is something matt was really
hoping to get and didn't
um but they're like these little alien
creatures that come to you and perform
surgery on you
if you have some type of
issue somewhere in your body they can
show up and
remedy that wow or
teach you maybe how to remedy it
yourself um but are very real little
aliens and it's like a consistent thing
that people will see they're like i got
celestial surgeons last night someone
else was like yeah so did i whoa
so that's the thing matt was really
hoping that these guys would come and
you know work on his hip work on his
knee
whatever um
but the like the things that you see in
common are very interesting and you're
in the jungle right so a lot of it is
jungle based too people will see
leopards or you know panthers
um snakes snakes is a common form that
mama aya comes to people as
um so it's it's so interesting hearing
people's stories and getting to see like
really really really vulnerable sides of
people and
and everyone has some type of trauma or
some type of baggage on some level that
they're there to work on and those 100
people that week like they become your
tribe like you learn their names you eat
all your meals with them and
they
hug you when you're crying and it's just
it's just this amazing community that
develops over the week and that was
something that matt and i really really
loved that's amazing yeah
because we're like man we don't really
feel like we're kind of just diving into
this world and we're so
in the strength and fitness and lifting
like we don't really know lots of people
that are going this route but having
this group of people
we need more people like this yeah we
need more people that we can connect
with on this level we need more peers
um
and and for us that was kind of
a stepping stone to like reaching out to
more people like you guys of like
finding those peers
finding those people you can connect
with and really building a community and
a tribe a group of people that you
really care about i think for us that
was uh
a really another important part of new
year's eve yeah cause i'm like this is
it like this feels kind of the same cool
and not that you're always searching for
that feeling but it's a good feeling
yeah like absolutely it's a good feeling
um the reason why i wanted you to share
this story is because i saw how
transformative it was for you like um
you were already such a confident person
and you were very kind and um i was
doing my research um and you were just
super supportive like just a positive
presence in in your space right your
space your community in life um but then
i remember
um you going through this sharing your
process and it was like
a different body yeah in a good way yeah
there's very much like a life
pre-ceremony and a life after yeah and i
don't think you realize it the week of
um but like looking back you're like oh
i'm so different i'm not even close to
that person i was going into that
ceremony i went in that highly skeptical
a highly atheist and now i'm like
yeah
some [ __ ] out there i very much think
there's divine powers at play i don't
know to what extent uh but yes 100
and
yet it's one really interesting thing is
that my taste in music changed
completely really you never went back
what was your taste before it went back
um more like hardcore punk like
alternative
more aggressive music when you um when
you say never going back meaning like
you don't choose that anymore but also
like you're the music that you grew up
listening to in your childhood does it
still bring back the nostalgic feelings
or no i don't really have any nostalgic
music from my childhood oh okay um or
like high school uh yeah yeah it brings
up those memories and that's fine and
good i just don't feel called to listen
to it i never want to turn it on and
when i do i'm like oh this is kind of
true that's kind of aggressive yeah like
i just want my vibey
edm
tribal like lo-fi yeah yeah i heard the
song you're playing and i was like i was
like bart you gotta hear this song i
love it i was like that song is sick
yeah but not to trade i saw her to go
lift to it i'm like i don't know how
you're gonna do that
right right and that's and i'm a bench
now yeah i'm like i feel pretty good you
were really doing that yeah
i was like don't leave yet you gotta
hear this song it's so good it's sick
song like we need to drive through red
rock with the windows down i'm like
that's what it makes me feel like this
song is the desert but she's like but
this makes me on a bench
[Music]
and it's uh i just need it upbeat enough
like it doesn't matter what it's doing
as long as it's upbeat enough then it's
good um but it's happened for matt too
he doesn't listen to anything he was
listening before and like we both just
craved that
and that's been one really solid like
lasting lasting change and you don't
realize how different you are until you
really look back and i'm like oh man me
in 2018 was someone so different yeah i
am now yeah oh so different but it's i
mean we're given that freedom yeah we're
given that freedom to change and grow
and develop and that's what's so
important and special about it yeah and
i'm so grateful that you were so raw to
share this experience and this story
because what i love and the people i
love to be around and this is the reason
why i'm so motivated and inspired by you
and i [ __ ] adore you is the fact that
um
you always dictate where your life is
going yeah and and people don't
understand the power behind that are
these people in in that i've been around
right um my own personal experience
people just
seem to kind of just throw in the towel
yeah and and i they kind of just float
through life or let life happen to them
yeah you know and and i love that you
share this to to be like hey sometimes
you don't know what you're doing but you
just gotta jump in and figure it out
when you're there i also think it helps
to know how many people don't feel like
they know what they're doing yeah that
definitely helps people like what steps
did you take to start your business i'm
like well
i started seeing if people want to train
with me like yeah yo that's it dive in
and figure it out yeah um and i love
that you are like
um i just know i don't like it and i'm
gonna change what i don't like i don't
know how but i'm just
one foot in front of the other is gonna
be different than me having both feet
planted yo we're here for such an
incredibly short amount of time why
would you do anything you don't like
yeah i mean i'm barely trying to
understand that yeah i understand the
theory yes i get it right but i don't
think i've had you know knock on wood
but i don't think i've had too many um
um either life experiences or or run-ins
with
things being so in my face that it's
like it shakes me up or shakes me to my
core where it's like some shit's gotta
change like i understand the change and
i unders i've had heartbreak i've had a
bunch of [ __ ] happen where it it forces
me to change as a person and evolve but
not to the point where i'm like oh [ __ ]
time is [ __ ] ticking yeah and i i had
this conversation with matt a couple
weeks ago
you know because he started his
mentorship group and named it 1612. did
you guys hear the story yeah behind that
okay so
for for him
his moment was
realizing okay this is how many weeks i
have left to live when his father passed
away and matt was 31 and he's like oh
[ __ ] am i halfway because his dad was 16
right correct yeah and so i was like the
other day i was like oh i get it i'm
like i get why we get along so well
we both had those moments of really
coming face to face with your mortality
and that is what shifts that is what
creates that next level of
self-awareness because we're both like
oh [ __ ] we gotta go we gotta go we gotta
do we gotta see we have to do that right
[ __ ] now yeah
and so i'm like this is why we get along
so well i'm like i never like realized
what that thing was yeah but we both
have that same attitude because we both
had one of those moments in our lives
and mine you know was when i was 26 and
got that diagnosis and his was when he
was 31. and i'm like man
i almost wish i would have got that
diagnosis sooner so i would have had
that kick in the pants earlier in life
but obviously you can't look at things
that way
um but i was like i understand we both
are really really aware of our mortality
yeah and like have thought about death
a lot and how many people just avoid
that subject and avoid thinking about it
and avoid talking about it yeah and um
you know it's a bit taboo to talk about
and it's like why yeah this is a massive
thing we share in common here in this
american culture it's it's really bad
very taboo yeah
um
and is you know someone that has lost
his father and like yo parents get old
and they pass away and this is what
happens like and we need to talk about
it more it needs to be confronted it
needs to be these open conversations
because this is all happening
i saw a meme the other day and i really
really liked it and it was um
it wasn't funny or anything but it was
so impactful it was uh like this isn't a
joke this is just good um
it was this like little dude and he's
like shedding his skin and it just says
um why be afraid of death when death is
just like taking off a shoe that's too
tight
and i was like oh my god i love that
i love that so much a shoe that's too
tight yeah like this this sole is coming
out of
this
meat sac avatar shell whatever and it's
as effortless or as relieving as
relieving yeah yeah
and i was like
oh i love that i'm like what a great way
of looking at that and like a thing that
kind of
takes away some of that fear yeah it's
like um it's a reminder but it's not a
scary reminder yeah that makes sense
yeah it does it does make sense
um it absolutely makes sense
but i mean you know you never know how
you're going to go out and i think
that's the part that some people might
hold on to aka me interesting yeah the
conversation we had yesterday yeah that
sometimes i i i try not to think about
it in that way as you know like i try to
be very very positive i try to find the
silver lining in everything
um
so i don't ever dwell on [ __ ] like that
but it's not until we have these
conversations that i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
i can go out pretty [ __ ] up i can't
not yeah and you can be positive and you
can have that positivity and that hope
but still be realistic
like we can't avoid this yeah like we're
all just
marching towards us whether we like it
or not rich or poor
uh wherever you came from [ __ ] smart
or stupid we're all headed in the same
direction yeah time doesn't give a [ __ ]
right
so i i just think it's one of those
things that like should be discussed
more and openly and
without fear and
being able to you know feel really safe
with people you're talking about be
vulnerable and express these things um
and it's just another taboo thing in our
culture that we don't talk about amongst
other things yeah and uh that's
that's been the game changer for me it's
coming face to face with that and i love
how transparent you are with it and i
love and i'm so happy that you have a
platform and that you share it and you
use it for the betterment of society and
for good and the lifting community gets
really confused when i start diving into
spirituality yeah but i mean that's cool
you know like you're shifting at all
it's because it went from i saw your
instagram change from like
crazy meathead [ __ ] like yeah i could
spend all day here 5 46 in the gym oh
i'm never leaving so now like getting
more spiritual we're trying to empower
like only you have the power to change
it like
i love it i think it's cool too because
it's uh traditionally you almost think
it's mutually exclusive you know someone
that's like uh
science with the progressive overload
right there's like that and then when
you think of like someone that's like oh
it's more about the feeling how do you
feel you're like that's
but why does it have to be mutually
exclusive why can't you be both yeah
right well i think so many people are um
just obsessed with tying their identity
to a single thing yeah like we were kind
of talking about like the
athlete or the coach or whatever that
may be like we're humans we want to
belong to a group we want to have people
around us that are doing the same thing
and have the same passions and be a part
of a tribe whatever that thing is but
it's it's not a thing we have to do to
survive you know what i'm saying like we
don't have to be in a tribe for
protection and survival anymore we're
not at that point in human history um so
we can be these multi-faceted creatures
with different interests and different
hobbies and we don't have to just tie
our identity to that single thing and
also time your identity to a single
thing that's based on your body and your
physicality and your physical
capabilities it's a bummer yo that's
super dangerous yeah because you're
gonna age or you can get injured i
injured my back in 2018 and that was
another big shift for me um like okay i
can't powerlift the way i want to
what am i besides an athlete you're like
what am i beside the power what else do
i enjoy yeah you're like i'm going from
conventional not a sumo [ __ ] yeah who
can relate to that such a media chat no
one right some people actually are that
invested dude yeah and when you've lived
that identity for so long and put so
much stock into that thing
yeah it's a huge shift and i've had
clients you know that
whatever pops up and i'm like all right
let's talk about this before this gets
crazy and like mentally it's really hard
for you oh that's so good of you because
i've been through it i know like that
injury made me a better athlete a better
coach a better friend just probably a
better person to be around yeah because
i wasn't so obsessed with the gym um but
like okay let's talk about this what
else do you enjoy besides the gym what
else are you besides an athlete or
you're not sure let's figure that out
and this is through your uh coaching
your one-on-one client yeah i've got
one-on-one clients they get the they get
all those kind of talks from me but it's
important it's a thing that you need to
know what else what else are you besides
a mom what else are you besides a father
like
there's a ton yeah and there should be
there should be that's exactly it yeah
um people want so desperately to be a
thing and belong to a thing yeah it's
like well it's okay like it's okay
give yourself a little grace dude i
swear i could keep talking to you for
[ __ ] ever but we have to
wrap it up okay but i'm so
[ __ ] grateful that you're here i'm so
grateful for your time thank you for
sharing your truth your [ __ ] stories
all of it there's a lot and i feel like
it was just a tip honestly it's just a
tip it's literally just the tip of the
iceberg so i do or we do want to bring
you back on 100 um but where can people
find you they can find me on instagram
at bontro b-o-n-s-c-h-r-o and at
bondshow.com
let's go
thank you guys so much um this was such
a cool episode i [ __ ] i adore this
woman i love you look at you bart leave
the room can i just gush about you for a
minute because she gave me this amazing
introduction yeah
no no
but thank you so much i hope you got an
amazing takeaway from all these [ __ ]
beautiful gems that bonnie just shared
with everybody um thank you and we will
see you next
week mwah bye